believe it or not that's me this is a
story about the stupidest lie I have
ever told
ok so chicken I'm in this mansion living
like some millionaire in Albanian
mountains with a private helicopter
[Music]
there also is three of the best
snowboarders in the world here and then
we are all here to ride back country
which is tonight that's never been
touched by humans like basically if you
took a mountain range in the middle of
nowhere
covered in and snow and what most people
know of racing to black diamonds for
steepness this would be rates and this
flame this is the flames from how
containing hard ice trees sinkholes
caves and avalanches it's also not as
soft as it looks all because of this guy
cannot he is someone you'd call not
normal definitely not normal he emailed
me and said you wanna go on an epic
adventure to them but you had reading a
tree just making that up you told me to
make it up said it's made it up the
email actually said as follows
Dan would love to include you in our
annual movie we are going to be
helicopter snowboarding in Albania it's
pretty advanced stuff I just thought of
how cool it would look standing on an
Albanian mountaintop like some spy and I
get an anonymous call and a helicopter
suddenly shows
you know like mysterious and [ __ ] this
lame vision made me lie about my
snowboarding expertise to cut three
weeks after the sly I ended up in Tirana
Albania
[Music]
I headed through these icy mountains
which looked like the natural dye Jetix
of the ice falling would make a rad
track now the time had come to face the
real music the other pros that believed
I was a pretty badass snowboarding
[Music]
they are all sponsored by Nitro which is
like this passionate powerhouse of all
things snowboarding that's behind this
entire movie I'm a part of called
offline which is ironic because there's
no service anywhere and I'm forced to be
offline for a week straight this made me
act up I danced a lot and I never danced
I also started becoming increasingly
open and honest and and I told one of
the pros alias my big secret
[Music]
even though Elias was probably thinking
what the hell I was doing there he
agreed to show me a few tricks while the
others were doing Avalanche safety
drills
I'm not lying when I say this place is
gnarly
[Music]
[Applause]
I wasn't very good or better put as good
as I had envisioned you know being a
surfer my whole life and all which which
is a stupid assumption when it comes to
cliffs like these
the dreaded day with all the cameras and
other pros were going to tell me that
I'm a fraud had arrived and I was
[ __ ] myself
[Music]
I wanna cheat in my mine it's gonna be
fine it's gonna be fine in a cemetry we
got to the top of this mountain base has
looked better suited for base general no
it was covered in ice I had to get
hooked by a line onto this renegade
guide named rook then I almost fell into
a hole
well pros glide down
now I really had no other option to
smack
[Music]
[Music]
I pulled it off well I think at least
but it was time to come clean with klutz
and tell him that I lied about being
about our snowboard did this trip taught
me again that assuming something is easy
because a professional makes have looked
at there is hugely naive and that a
simple little lie leads to large amounts
of unnecessary anxiety a huge thank you
to cannot steam for keeping me alive I
love these guys definitely made a bunch
of friends for life and therefore I'm
gonna give their new movie or flying a
massive plug tell me about your op sign
so we're moving all about snowboarding
and getting people to go outside to do
something worth remembering I mean do
when you're on top of that mountain you
were fully offline I struggle to get off
line but do you guys there phanie helped
me because there's no internet yeah yeah
if you want to get offline go somewhere
there isn't ah okay offline equals never
[Music]
[Applause]
brooo I haven't been on the internet for
so long I actually feel like a stranger
yeah I so badly just want to turn this
camera around so that I can show you all
the plans that we have for season two
but I can't right now I can however tell
you some important dates like from next
week I'll start uploading on my other
social channels again and I leave to New
York and the 29th of April with a video
upload schedule begins in the beginning
of May I took a lot of time to plan and
strategize with my team so that I don't
miss an upload once I begin the season
other than that don't forget your
awesome brew and I'll see you next next
next next week wings
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]